ukraine has rejected a russian proposal
for humanitarian corridors ukraine's
deputy prime minister said it was not an
acceptable option because the planned
routes out of several ukrainian cities
only led to russia or its ally belarus
kiev also accuses the kremlin of
continuing to shell civilians during
previously agreed ceasefires to help
people escape
overnight russian forces stepped up
their bombardment of several cities
across the country according to
ukrainian officials there were reports
of heavy shelling in hathief in the east
nicolaev in the south and sherniv in the
north as well as in the outskirts of
kiev
now ukrainian president vladimir
silanski says his country will not
forgive russia for the suffering the war
is causing here's a part of his latest
address
we will not forgive the shooting of
unarmed people
the destruction of our infrastructure
we won't forgive hundreds and hundreds
of victims
thousands and thousands of sufferings
and god won't forgive
not today
not tomorrow
in that address zelensky also spoke of a
family killed by russian shelling they
were trying to escape the town of europe
near kiev authorities say at least eight
civilians were killed as they tried to
flee and we want to warn you that this
report contained some distressing images
this video captures the moment a mortar
blast hits the town of earpin
people are making a desperate dash to
safety
taking only what they can carry
residents climb over a bombed out bridge
praying they make it out before the
shelling returns
not everyone does
it's risky to leave but perhaps riskier
to stay
the city's infrastructure has been
decimated by days of fighting
leaving residents without heat
electricity and water supplies are
running thin
there is no
no possibility physically to do any
supply
no bread no milk no eggs no nothing and
all the chemistry is closed and
it's terrible
ukrainian authorities say the russian
army has stepped up its shelling of
residential areas
russian forces blew up the railway
station here so now ambulances and vans
are being used to evacuate people to
nearby kiev
but with the russian assault getting
closer to cave it may not be long before
they have to flee once again
let's get an update on the situation on
the ground now we have our correspondent
nick connolly in the ukrainian capital
kiev nick it's good to see you i want to
start with uh some of these reports that
we're seeing that the evacuation routes
out of ukrainian cities are leading into
russia and belarus that hasn't been
confirmed yet but what would that mean
well obviously that would be a kind of
for now seemingly unlikely scenario this
is something that's on paper obviously
russia wanted to show that it is not
trying to uh cause damage to ukraine's
civilian population we've heard all that
rhetoric from the kremlin talking about
ukrainian's brother nation even though
russia obviously willing to use
considerable force not just against the
ukrainian army but against ukrainian
civilians in recent days i think it's
very unlikely this is going to get off
the ground we've seen a lot less
ambitious plans for humanitarian
corridors out of marryable in the far
east of the country which is now
surrounded on three sides with the sea
on the other and two attempts to
organize a temporary ceasefire to let
civilians out have failed ukrainian side
has accused the russians of breaking
that ceasefire of breaking their
commitments um i think it's just very
difficult to see right now at a time
where hundreds of soldiers on both sides
are dying every day it's very difficult
to see how they can even get to the
table and come to some kind of agreement
without outside
mediation and outsider like the red
cross bringing them together because
there just isn't the trust between both
sides right now nick can you tell us how
things have been there in the capital
kiev
here in kiev it's kind of eerie and
nervy i think so far kiev hasn't seen
the kind of airstrikes that we've seen
in other big cities especially kharkiv
in the east where you've had significant
bombing of buildings government
buildings but also of
private civilian accommodation of
residential districts for now it's more
the fear of russian sleeper agents there
is the expectation that there will be
more attempts on president vladimir's
life more attempts by russia to get rid
of that democratically elected ukrainian
leadership and install their own uh
puppet leadership as it were here in
kiev so there's that kind of fear of
strangers of agents still here we've
heard from intelligence ukrainian
intelligence today i think there are
still lots of cells of these sleeper
agents on the ground who were on the
ground before this war started heavily
armed and ready to do damage so there's
a kind of emptiness and a fear here an
expectation of worse things to come
nick what about the situation facing
civilians we know several major cities
are under siege we heard a civilian say
in an earlier report there's no bread
there is no supply
on the ground there so what is the
situation of facing them
well it depends where you are here in
kiev there still are roots open from the
south south west so food is coming in
you can't get everything but you can get
the basics and obviously people most
people have supplies and they still for
now haven't had to kind of start using
them they can still go out and buy stuff
but in places like kharkiv it's it's
much much worse where we have seen
significant damage to residential
districts also gas pipelines people left
without heating it's still pretty cold
here and i think most crucially for
people's morale it's about mobile phone
networks in mario paul in the far east
people have now spent a few days without
mobile phone connection reliable uh
reliable connections and that really
takes people's chance to kind of find
out what's going on
around in the country is a wider kind of
situation stops them from contacting
their families and their
friends so i think that really is the
most difficult thing i think as long as
people have that connection to the
outside world and get some kind of sense
of the potential to get out or support
from the government we've seen some
towns retaken by ukraine's government
today i think they can for now sit this
out but i think cut off cut off from any
communication that is going to be the
real test of people's morale and their
ability to kind of sit this out
nick conley reporting for us there thank
you for that update from kiev
western ukraine has remained relatively
safe so far with the heaviest fighting
concentrated in other parts of the
country but ukraine's defense forces are
preparing for a possible russian attack
locals are worried about what might
happen if the war reaches their doorstep
dw's alexander fundament reports
a checkpoint on the outskirts of lutzg
in northwestern ukraine sasha baroda is
one of the local fighters who have
joined ukraine's defense forces he tells
me that morale among the troops remains
high despite the dire situation in the
country
at the moment it is calm here
we are preparing the defense of lutsk
and the region with everything we have
at the same time we're helping those who
volunteer to join the army and deploy to
the front in the east and to defend our
ukraine
life still seems to go on here in
western ukraine despite the heavy
fighting that is taking place in other
parts of the country and yet residents
tell us they want to be ready for
whatever might come next
at the beginning of its invasion russia
targeted an airfield not far from the
city
the military airport in ludzk was one of
the first facilities hit by russian
missiles in ukraine since then it's been
relatively quiet here in the region but
people are scared that it's just a
matter of time before the war comes here
[Music]
they seek comfort through prayers in the
local church the sermon that day urges
the churchgoers to forgive those who
have done them wrong
this is a truly christian message father
roman tells me but one that it's so hard
to follow right now
i wish i had never seen that day
that he had died before
it's really hard to keep living
outside the church valentina receives a
blessing for a safe journey she is not
in good health and wants to leave for
neighboring poland
it is so hard to leave of course
hard to leave my children and my
grandchildren here
she goes with a heavy heart what seems
to be hopeful ukraine will prevail she
says
and our correspondent alexander fornamen
is in live in western ukraine alexandra
how is the situation where you are right
now
well the night here from what i can say
was quite quiet
i was waiting every second for the um
air aid air alert for the sirens to go
over it was the case the night before
but as i said the night was
very quiet it is good news for everyone
here in life in the western ukraine but
i spoke with many people here residents
of
the city also residents of other cities
north of kiev and they are very
concerned they are scared that it's just
a matter of time before the war comes
here as well i spoke with the priest he
was telling me that he believes that
putin is the devil that he is just
waiting you know for more people more
refugees to come together he will live
to attack the city and that is just
showing you uh the fears here and how
people are just really scared what might
come next
just how full is this city becoming i
mean it's located near the polish border
and i guess it's becoming a transit
point for so many refugees uh the the
way west being the only way out of the
country at the moment
well that's uh you're totally right that
that's the case here and i was at the
border during the weekend and we saw
there
a lot of families with small kids
waiting in the middle of night to cross
the border i was at the border crossing
at tribenka and we also saw long lines
of cars going on for kilometers with
people trying to
escape
the country trying to get over to poland
to feel safe there however there are
also people who told me that they
decided against
traveling to poland because they are
still hoping that this war will be over
soon and some of them of course decided
to stay
because they don't want to leave their
families behind their houses before
behind and as you know
men
are not allowed to
leave the country well let's hope that
it is over soon but alexandra at the
moment we're getting his mixed messages
from moscow uh these humanitarian
corridors that they're announcing in
several cities um
some of them uh over the weekend then
failing because um fighting continued
well that's that's true and of course
that is why many here are skeptical
whether it's really going to be possible
to evacuate residents of
cities such as mariopol for example well
people do not have any access to water
to electricity where the situation is
dire or really it's a
need for people to get out to get to to
get to safety according to the ukrainian
side it was russia to be blamed that
two attempts to
get those humanitarian corridors
to work and to evacuate people that
those attempts failed now we are hearing
from the russian defense ministry that
they are ready to make it possible for
residents to leave mariupol to leave
kiev for instance but of course there is
a lot of skepticism here that this is
really uh going to happen
alexandra naaman thank you very much for
the update there from lev in the west of
ukraine
let's get around up some other headlines
now japan has called russia's attack on
ukraine's largest nuclear facility an
unforgivable outrageous act russian
soldiers took the zaporichia facility on
friday after shelling it and have
reportedly turned off its intranet and
telephone lines the u.n nuclear watchdog
has also voiced its concern reliable
communications are critical to nuclear
plant safety
and several nations are calling on
interpol to suspend russia from the
organization immediately that's
according to the british home secretary
the country cite the threat to public
safety from russia's invasion of ukraine
the law enforcement body is a network of
194 countries
you